was für ein klick bildtitel ich mir
überlegt habe damit ihr auf dieses video
klickt aber ich wollte ankündigen die
brauchen bisschen pause
hätte
ich habe mir eine pause verdient
[Musik]
fertig
mein balkon ist einfach zu klein
habe ich da nicht
gedacht
was machst du dir fast
keine zu hause und auch keinen
[Musik]
kommentar
und so machte ich mich auf den weg
timo kann sie mich bitte nach hamburg
fahren um den garten meiner eltern zu
retten meine routinen aufzubrechen und
meinem langweiligen bereit erklären
[Applaus]
jetzt aber mal spaß beiseite meine
eltern haben diesen garten über jahre
aufgebaut gepflegt sachen eingepflanzt
um gepflanzt und meine mutter liebt ihn
aber in den letzten jahren konnten wir
überhaupt nichts mehr hier wirklich
machen bei die zeit gefehlt hat und vor
allem auch mit kraft und deswegen hat
dieser garten einfachen makeover
verdient zuhause im glück und was ist
jetzt mein großartiger plan player ich
werde alles aufräumt zum sperrmüll
fahren pflanzen treffen sie sind kürzer
schneiden die wege frei machen und hier
und da eine lampe stellen ihr seht ja
schon im hintergrund und um euch nochmal
ein ganz klares bild von diesem garten
zu machen hier ein paar vorher schaut
[Musik]
hallo mein garten griff
ok also wir sind hier im vorgarten da
sind pflanzen die alle so ein bisschen
glaube ja so beschnitten werden müssen
und dann kommt man so an haus und land
wo ganz tolle pflanzen zum beispiel
angebaut werden also hier das ist die
gartenprojekt meiner mutter hier sowas
muss halt alles aufgeräumt werden
gefehlt und jetzt geht's in den hinteren
bereich die terrasse sieht katastrophal
aus aber denkt daran wir haben einen
jungen hinsicht kann muss
er wird geschlossen
das war ein ganz toller zen-garten wie
hier ist erkennen können dann ist so ein
wasserspiel also dass aus dem stein
kommt wasser raus und ich finde nichts
streit mehr sein aus als diese
bepflanzung auf diesen tollen steilen
das was ich meide oder krabbelt auch
ganz weh aber ich freue mich ja und da
ist halt alles zugewachsen
falls jemand noch ein tisch braucht
meldet sich gerne da haben wir noch ein
hier könnt ihr ganz gut dieses unkraut
dilemma das ist halt einfach dass dieses
motto zieht sich durch den ganzen garten
seiner so und das motto zieht sich
irgendwie auch durch den ganzen garten
wir haben mal was abgeschnitten und
jetzt lassen wir es da liegen einfach
nur groß meine erhöht hat ja der teil da
hinten im gartenhaus ich sag mal so wer
beschreibt die situation hier auch ganz
gut wie dabei ist schön ausgedrückt
die natur so langsam alles zurückgeholt
ein positiver punkt manchmal wenn ich in
diesem garten fühlte sich ein bisschen
an wie bei allen wunderland die haben
den wirklich schön bepflanzt und er ist
so schön zugewachsen nur halt die so das
ist eine wiese das teil nicht da muss
halt rasen gemäht werden würde
in diesem sandkastenspiele ich ganz
gerne hier und da habe ich zum beispiel
meine und welche mit dem staat so
einfach entspannen da hier kann man gut
den teil sehen immer
noch dafür dass wir diesen
stellt die leute schafft und jetzt bin
ich richtig motiviert meine routine
aufzubrechen meinem alltag zu entfliehen
und diesen garten aufzuräumen der
schlauch ist nicht mehr funktionsfähig
zeichnet
lebten gar nicht anders angegeben sein
muss
[Musik]
wie vor unklar
er war natürlich klar dass ich das nicht
alleine schaffen werde was ich brauchte
sind helfer und einen guten plan den ich
mit dem chromebook erstellt hat
mit dem chromebook konnte ich mein
projekt perfekt planen es lässt sich
super intuitiv bedienen
mit den über 2,1 millionen apps im place
tor hatte ich eine riesenauswahl um auf
kreative weise mein garten projekt zu
planen und durch das einrichten von
mehreren benutzeroberflächen kann das
chromebook von der ganzen familie
benutzt werden und die privatsphäre wird
dabei geschützt und selbst wenn es auch
mal keine internetverbindung gibt mit
dem comic kunst auch weiterhin produktiv
sein
[Musik]
heute wird ein schöner tag also heute
ist der erste offizielle tag würde ich
sagen denn heute kommt patrick das ist
ein freund von uns der als gärtner und
meine schwester kommen mit ihren kindern
und ihrem partner der auch nochmal an
kann und so also ich glaube dieses
projekt mit ein bisschen größer als ich
es mir vorgestellt hab' wenn ich zu
diesem zeitpunkt gewusst hätte was auf
mich zukommt
ich will auch sagen letzte
gekommen fängt vorne schon an und ich
suche gerade meinte klitschko
er schneidet die büsche es ist auch
interessant kommt per link sofort los
das war den ich hab dem hallo gesagt und
er gleich so ja ich fange mal an
das projekt fängt an und immer wenn man
so ein projekt plant dann hat man sie
vorstellung wie das alles so abläuft
aber noch nicht so richtig klar als
patrick gekommen es war es wie ein
schalter der sich um gelegt hat und der
staat für dieses projekt
ja ja die weg will ich die von den
steines lösen wir auch abstellen
das
ist der plan genommen wird von bernd
wird hier erst mal schneiden schneiden
[Musik]
aber sie wächst nach neu delhi fliegen
er ist als unkraut oder ist das eher
blume die da bleiben sollte
sie hat sich lange werden von der gruppe
abgesondert sie macht ihr eigenes ding
und hat sich auch das einzige was ich
kann so ein bisschen von canstein
wegschneiden das ist das noch zu aber
der rest
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich kann nicht glauben ich sie so einen
vorgarten an blättern einfach hat aber
wenn man den gesehen hat dann kann man
sich schon vorstellen dass da noch mehr
verstärkung bekommen wir nun ja hier
kein fleisch verarbeiter also der es
wirklich sein geld wert würde ich sagen
ja
[Musik]
wir sind dann weiter in den garten rhein
wo julian einfach büschelweise gras
rausgezogen hat aber nicht sein gras
sondern sind unkraut gras ich weiß nicht
mal wie das heißt der ackerschachtelhalm
auch zehn kraut ak 10 kraut 10 gras
katzen wedel katzenschwanz pferdeschwanz
schafft heute butter oder sauerkraut
genannt ist eine pflanzenart aus der
klasse der schachtelhalm
patrick hat einfach ganz allein patrick
gemacht und hat mit seiner schere alles
kurz geschnitten und ich habe einfach
noch ein bisschen versucht den platz in
meinem leben zu finden vor dem
gartenhaus ich habe wirklich versucht
ordnung reinzubringen ja ich hab's
wirklich versucht aber es war so viel
und da wurde mir wirklich bewusst dass
fünf tage die wir dafür eingeplant haben
vielleicht nicht ausreichend
hallo willkommen zu tag nummer zwei
heute kommt der trödeltrupp also patrick
mit seinem großen anhänger und wir
werden den ganzen sperrmüll
zusammensammeln es glaubst oder nicht es
gibt hier einiges an sperrmüll kino es
gestern schon mit meinem neffen töpfe
und heime und verhältnis auch eine menge
als wäre ein haufen gemacht ich hoffe
meine mutter wird nichts davon vermissen
ich glaube sie weiß nicht mal dass sie
das besitzt deswegen machen wir es
einfach mal und ja jetzt gerne bei
der tat
paprika julian minuten zu spät der
bauherr wird schon genannt
ich kann mich mal beschreiben was das
für den sperrmüll war das war gefühlt
alles ausverkauft sommerschlussverkauf
alles muss raus
[Musik]
das team von da zusammenklicken damit
ich mich nicht vor laufender kamera
blamiere wenn es beim militär heute
sonntag ist und wir keine versuchen und
hier keine kettensägen benutzt wird
[Musik]
sie haben es nicht geschafft aufzunehmen
weil die zu schnell waren aber meine
sandkiste weg wo spiele ich denn jetzt
mit einem wassereimer stock
wir haben nicht die
vollen anhänger mit stämmen
das gefühl der garten ist immer ein
bisschen komisch aus mama ich hab
gerettet was sich retten konnte bitte
glaubt nicht dass das hier ne ich hab
die kopie
und er hat den hunsrück strahler hier
gelassen und ja ich hochdruck strahlen
[Musik]
sie ist es könne
und wie jeden abend kam ahmed nach der
arbeit und weiter das dach zu streichen
danke ahmed tag nummer zwei ist jetzt
vorbei es regnet was natürlich meinen
pflanzen ganz gut tut und jetzt
feierabend
hallo ganz kurz kommt auf meine bank
schon trocken ist wir kommen zu tag
nummer vier wir waren heute schon
fleißig und zwar waren wir im baumarkt
um nach einer neuen hollywood schaukel
zu suchen wisst ihr was wir nicht
gefunden haben eine hollywoodschaukel
aber dafür eine aufbewahrungsbox das war
ganz toll und jetzt an deren planung
schon fleißig und ich weiß noch nicht so
ganz dass mein place heute ist wir
müssen noch ganz viel grünzeug
abschneiden also der ganze hinteren
garten ist noch nicht beschnitten als er
am sonntag nicht machen konnten ja ich
würde mal sagen let's go heute ist es
schon wieder komplett heißt
wetteransager meinte ganze zeit es
regnet aber
wenn jetzt einen busch entfernt da diese
viel angst vor aber dann nimmt sie sich
trägt dass der weg muss von außen oder
muss ich erstmal stützen
finden sie hier
[Musik]
ich habe gerade mit diesem job gegenteil
versuchen so und jetzt zeigen wir
zwischen profit machen würde würde ich
nicht damit
ja ja
[Musik]
an tag 4 am montag kam dann auch endlich
an um zu helfen an die ihr könnt sie und
an ihn hatte lästig war
[Musik]
sie haben es alle schwer
das schnell
der große bär
er braucht rosen lee bedeutet wer
[Musik]
super dass man jetzt kann man nach da
gucken und du kannst auf dem färben ganz
anderes
[Musik]
also das mit dem beet ausheben und
dieses ganze immergrünen draus machen
war zwar eine gute idee sieht toll aus
tipptopp richtig luft ich plötzlich aber
das ist halt auch scheiße viel arbeit
habe ich meine managerin gehört
[Musik]
das sieht man jetzt vielleicht nicht so
gut aber als wir den baum rausgerissen
haben ist uns aufgefallen dass wir auch
gleich das ganze grünzeug rausreißen
können turns out es war super
anstrengend wir haben dazu dritt drei
stunden lang gebuddelt rausgezogen weil
das so krass verwurzelt war ich würde
gerne das zu den kirche
hochdruckreiniger
[Musik]
natürlich wollte ich auch machen
meine hände reichen langsam nach fuß
aber
das beet ist frei wie viel stück hat das
jetzt gedauert welche uhrzeit ist ein
jahr haben wir bestimmt
wir haben heute bremsen party handy
wurde schon drei mal gesprochen nun wird
es auch schon gestanden
ich bin ich mir war schon von vornherein
klar dass meine eltern einen schönen
garten haben und wir den eigentlich nur
aufräumen müssen aber dass sich noch so
viel verändert wie zum beispiel mit dem
beet technisch gedacht also das war
einfach so ein unterschied wie tag und
nacht und eine heidenarbeit aber halt
auch ein tolles ergebnis wenn die steine
sogar wieder freigelegt
aber lernt dazu also wenn ich das zum
ersten tag die gleiche dann ist es viel
besser melanie
profi am werk aber ein profi am werk
hier
[Musik]
die massen fragen ist es spaßig
wow effekt der bauherr begutachtet
wieder
[Musik]
kabelsalat manchmal
es war sehr schwer das kann ich muss
immer gucken wie viel braucht sie gerade
um wieder zurückziehen damit wie immer
das gefühl hat von freiheit von sehr gut
das war richtig und wichtig das ergebnis
lässt sich doch an kollegen hat er jetzt
auch gerade vor so gearbeitet haben wie
der englische garten hier ja der ist
auch wichtig jetzt verstehe ich dass mit
diesen ewig vielen buchsbäumen vorher
sah das haus wie grün grün grün grün
ja
[Gelächter]
jetzt geht's wieder
[Musik]
hallo
also patrick ist weg aber eigentlich
wollten wir feiern machen und plötzlich
sagt timo
wir haben 20 tausend schritte gemacht
[Musik]
wir sind fertig mit der terrasse und mit
dem leben und mit dem leben wir haben
komplett hier einmal spinnenweben
weggespritzt boden sauber gespritzt
richtig ein abgespritzt das brauchen
sollte
hallo ich möchte ihnen hier und vor
allem was machen diese kissenbezüge hier
ist heute etwa tag nummer fünf und damit
feinschliff tag wir haben gestern so
viel geschafft und heute geht es
eigentlich darum ja ist fertig zu machen
so weit dass wir die licht elektronik
setzen können bei der planung musste ich
mir ein lichtkonzept ausdenken also habe
ich mir in mut bord gemacht und einfach
mal überlegt wie soll das ganze aussehen
und dann hab ich ganz viel bestellt und
einfach gehofft dass es funktioniert
weil mein professionelles lichtkonzept
natürlich so krass war mussten wir
erstmal schauen wie beleuchten wir
überhaupt die terrasse und dann ging es
auch mal an den tisch wenig schleifen
sollte also habe ich gesagt hey
praktikers und schleifgerät und er sagt
ja und ich war kann ich das bitte
benutzen fünf minuten später sehe ich
patrick in der prallen sonne diesen
fisch schleifen aber ich durfte ihnen
danach auch lackieren mit einem viel zu
kleinen pinsel und in der prallen sonne
was ist ein bisschen schwieriger gemacht
hat aber ich habe wirklich mühe gegeben
und alle tischler die das gesehen haben
ein so sorry wir machen halt diese
ganzen kleinigkeiten geradezu den
kleinigkeiten gehörte auch die reifen
box für meinen vater aufbauen warum
wusste ich dass er einen reichen box
haben möchte weil er mir das ungefähr
dreimal erzählt hatte ich glaube es war
schon so ein kleiner wink mit dem
zaunpfahl
zaunpfahl das macht jetzt hier noch viel
mehr sind ja auf jeden fall habe ich mit
meiner besten freundin altes tina feys
zusammengebaut
[Musik]
als er das sehr wichtig dass die
oder sie wächst auf
und hier seht ihr mich in der russen
heute vor der fertigen reifen boxt aber
wenn du diese reifen box nicht magst ich
[Musik]
habe mir ein lichtsystem ausgesucht an
dem man die eine lampe mit der anderen
verbinden kann und dann halt ein konzept
daraus macht das bedeutet aber auch dass
man schauen muss wo geht denn dieses
kabel an wofür das denn überhaupt hin
und was wird am ende beleuchtet und wie
funktioniert das überhaupt kann man die
kabel am ende sehen kann man sie nicht
sehen kann man sie irgendwie gut
verstecken das musste eigentlich genug
patrick sich überlegen an ihr und ich
waren zum hundertsten mal im baumarkt
und haben sachen gekauft in geld
ausgegeben marie ist beendet jetzt wäre
es zeit stativ aus
mir ist eine sache aufgefallen ich schon
vorher wusste aber ich wollte sie immer
nicht wahrhaben wir müssen halt die
steine sortieren um wirklich den
richtigen effekt zu haben mit denen
stellen
das sind alles falsche steine die können
wir leider nicht benutzen aber die also
verloren sind sie nicht weil wir werden
sie irgendwo anders benutzen auf jeden
fall nur damit ihr versteht was steine
sortieren heißt die celli greifen
überwerfen greifen rüber werfen und auf
der anderen seite genau das gleiche die
schwarzen wieder zurück es sieht
mühselig aus und übertrieben aber es
muss sein und dann taten wir was wir tun
mussten steine sortieren to do liste der
letzten zehn jahre
[Musik]
unser beta schon richtig richtig gut aus
aber es hat einfach was gefehlt die erde
sei ein bisschen komisch aus trocken und
einfach nicht ansprechen deswegen hat
mich gefragt was wir machen sollen und
er hat gesagt wir sollen so pinien
scheiße pinien mulch kinderhand da
kaufen und darüber lägen also haben wir
weiter steinchen sortiert mit einem
schönen kirchen und team hat noch ein
bisschen erde abgetragen dann haben wir
die pinien zeug swingen echtes
rinderhack darauf gemacht
das machen wir einfach
ein bisschen größer
jetzt schon die technik hätte dieses
beet sah danach so gut aus halo ist hier
gerade meine steine denn es ist der
letzte tag und wir sind wieder in den
baumarkt gefahren weil es schon wieder
irgendwas nicht gab irgendwelche
verteiler steckdosen nagel stellen weil
wir vorher die falschen gekauft haben
und deko natürlich und während ich da so
einen shopping ausflug hatte hat hat
mich wirklich alle lampen auf ihre
positionen gepackt und es hat
funktioniert die kabel waren lang genug
ich war so schockiert und das allerbeste
es hat von anfang an geklappt das
chromebook mit dem smart home system zu
verbinden und mit einem knopfdruck
gelangt man zu machen ich war einfach
nur patrick werden
[Musik]
ein
das gab es mal meinungsverschiedenheiten
und so ein paar situationen wo
vielleicht ein streit hätte entstehen
können
bis zum vorsichtiger
[Musik]
kuranyi macht das wieder mit so ner
halbherzigkeit weil sie gar keinen bock
drauf hat natürlichkeit guck doch mal
bildet das tor hinten an was das stück
kleine winkel hatte wo du kein punkt
mehr drauf hatte
aber es war halt auch so eine anspannung
da unseren stress und ich glaube das hat
uns alle irgendwie so die nerven geraubt
dass nur eine kleine sache passieren
musste und irgendwer ist schon wieder
explodieren weil ich ein blatt angewandt
habe
ich habe dir
im lieb das ist aber offiziell aber wir
haben natürlich weiter an einem strang
gezogen auch wenn man manchmal nicht
wollte aber die anderen haben einen
wieder mitgenommen
profi wurde das ist natürlich nicht so
machen aber bei dir unter extremen
zeitmangel leiden müssen wir hier so ein
bisher in velten auch das passiert dann
halt auch dass ein rosenblatt angemalt
also gleich kommt immer eine schoko
banane wieder hoch
und alles wochenende
sie sind jetzt richtig im endspurt ihr
könnt sehen die lampen sind alle
installiert die spots stehen schon mal
heute abend wenn es dunkler wird gucken
wir ob sie die bäume richtig an strahlen
dann verstecken wir auch noch die
letzten kabel damit das wirklich
aussieht als ob einfach über licht wäre
und man keine kabel sieht ja wenn eltern
sind in wie viele stunden da 18 jetzt
müssen wir noch dekoriert und wirklich
tigers geben let's go
ja
[Musik]
und dann waren wir fertig es gab nichts
mehr zu tun außer einer sache dekorieren
und das war mein teenager moment
die praktischen sachen sind jetzt
erledigt jetzt geht es um die
hallo mein name ist tine wittler und ich
verschönere ihren garten zuhause im
glück
meine schwester fett weg waren gerade
oder sind fertig gebaut mit dem garten
ich war duschen und habe danach 15
minuten lang geheult vor erleichterung
vor erschöpfung vor ich weiß nicht was
es alles war und jetzt geht es nur noch
ums dekorieren hier ist noch ein
schandfleck der ge tine wittler muss
sein muss aber wir haben jetzt einen
ganz einfachen trick wir nehmen eine
schöne tagesdecke die für draußen
geeignet ist und herr legen sie darüber
[Applaus]
dass man kürzen zum vergleich
und natürlich brauchen wir neue
seidenkissen weil das geht ja gar nicht
auch in einem tollen
und es ist sogar so einer decke zum hals
in einem guten garten dürfen keine
figuren fehlen deswegen gibt es ständig
er ist so sie hätte auch ganz viele
figuren kaufen können ich war auf ganz
verliebt in die figuren dann werde ich
meine religion hier ein bisschen
verteidige dollar und weil sowohl hängen
kommt in unseren garten dem endlich
gesenkt haben der tine wittler moment
hamam
oder auch mit der fall wir da oben
sie haben sogar neuer stuhl auflagen
geholt und ich habe sogar die griffe von
den stühlen
strich
moment sieht es gut aus
und jetzt hier dachte das wäre das
highlight und ein
assist und
flur an diesen kissing sie sind
abwaschbar abwischbar
tine wittler moments zu haue das würde
ich auch gerne als schal tragen
leite und jetzt der tine wittler moment
auch an wir sind wir sind in ausstatter
who
und jetzt ist es zeit für den
allerletzten schliff
[Musik]
stammkeeper burg
bis 13
und heute ist der tag der tage meine
eltern sind gerade auf dem weg nach
hause wir werden ihnen gleich den garten
zeigen und ich bin einfach überwältigt
von dem
ausmaß der
sich hier zugetragen hat das was wir
geschafft haben absolut unglaublich ich
habe mein alltag wirklich einmal
verändert ich habe eine neue routine
entwickelt und es hat mir so viel spaß
gemacht ich bin ich bin einfach nur
dankbar und ich hoffe meine eltern jetzt
auch let's go
ich hab so zittrige bein als wie muss
ich mich auf die bank setzen zu meinem
opa
hatten mit den stichwahl ich gearbeitet
habe man schläft
die meine eltern sind heute morgen um
halb zwei uhr nachts hat er mir
geschrieben habe
computer
[Applaus]
am schluss sind eingebrochen
dass so viele da war die auswahl nicht
so schön
so was
hab ich das vor dem urlaub das alter
abgemacht ich bin aufgeregt
suzuka seinen bank ist gestrichen
ich wollte ihn immer weiß haben um
[Musik]
21 altenkirchen das ist hier so alt marl
hat man wer das gemacht
das war mein schwiegersohn
[Musik]
wo hast du denn gegriffen
weil so viele
[Musik]
das ist
also ich bin ich weiß nicht
[Musik]
ich als gewaltgeneigt lassen warnt aber
seine leute
[Musik]
genau weißt du was sagst du
jetzt meine erste aufregung weg ich bin
jetzt berichtete er
[Musik]
oh wie schön ist
im prospekt sind wie meint es nicht zu
beschreiben und
jedes
[Musik]
und jetzt weiter
das ist für meine
wir wollen
jetzt nicht auf sorgsam das ist eine
rose von aldi
wir haben uns hier zusammengeschlossen
in diesem halbdunklen um york zu
erleuchten oder garten nummer eins
ja
mein gott
ich muss diesen effekt wenn ich da raus
kommen
und nein dafür will ich nie wieder
stoppen
[Musik]
co
und so ging ich in meine freie momente
hier zu sein kaffee trinken und
am ende wird das nicht mehr angenehm
weil letztes jahr war ich krank und ich
habe nichts gemacht und das war
plötzlich zu viel
[Musik]
nicht fahren
wir haben alle auf diesen moment
hingearbeitet und ich habe mir viele
gedanken gemacht ob der garten so bleibt
ob sie sich darum kümmern werden und mir
ist aufgefallen dass das gar nicht so
wichtig ist dass es jetzt mein
erwartungen immer entspricht sondern der
weg dahin hat einfach so spaß gemacht
einen so gefordert
und diese teamarbeit von uns allen
zusammen ich konnte mich auf alle
verlassen alle haben an einem strang
gezogen und das war tatsächlich das
erste mal dass ich so ein gefühl hatte
dass wir alle eine gemeinschaft waren
die auf eine sache hingearbeitet haben
ich habe nach hilfe gefragt das fällt
mir sonst so schwer nach hilfe zu fragen
und in diesen tagen habe es einfach
gelernt dass es leute gibt die einen
helfen wenn man die hilfe braucht
also am ende mit
dass es so untergegangen ist sehr bitter
sagte ebert der enterbten das sind
paradies
ich kann so einen routinen weg von
echtem empfehlen besonders grenzen mami
glücklich macht
gerichte hirsch in glems und zwar jetzt
auch den geburtstagsgeschenken
nächsten zehn jahre ist das absolut
[Musik]